so have you ever called a really
important person at a really important
business probably in a really important
really big building and does never take
you five to ten secretaries to actually
get to the really important person
probably sitting in front of a really
big really important desk and I'm pretty
sure it probably goes a little bit to
something like this high is really
important Joe there
you don't yeah sure that's fine
hi yeah is this really important Joe's
other dusts yeah it is can I just can
you just hold her just one more minute
please thank you Joe are you free I just
need a few more run up and you just
continue to hold while you're tossed
around from person to person to finally
get to talk to the person that you need
to talk to it's insanity it ever
happened to you guys
does it drive you crazy how do you cope
with being put on hold